we're starting off this morning with
really one of my favorite scholars in
one of the most interesting spaces I
think we've been talking about this
question of what the open Internet means
for the public sphere and one of the
questions that's really come up in this
is what does the open Internet mean for
social movements does it make it easier
for people to get together and protest
at government is it harder to govern in
this age is it easier to foment
revolution there are people who have
been arguing all sorts of different
sides of this case you have people
essentially saying that once we have
facebook and the ability to organize
groups governments fall very quickly
people take to the streets you have
other people essentially saying that's
madness that's craziness what really
matters is people's offline ties
probably in my opinion the most
insightful and nuanced voice in this
space is the voice of our next speaker
Zeynep too fishy Zeynep is a sociologist
she teaches at UNC
she's also visiting at Princeton at the
moment she's been over at Harvard's
Berkman Center for those of you who hang
out with us at center for civic media
you met her a couple of times she's
coming and given a couple of talks
Zeynep started working on these
questions of media and social change
looking at the Arab Spring looking at
Tunisia looking at Egypt and then this
same sort of disruptive social media
connected protest came to her native
Turkey and she has now been going back
and forth between the u.s. and Turkey
trying to understand all that's been
going on she just flew in from Turkey
boyer her arms tired we are so happy to
have her here
Zeynep to fishing
thank you everyone I apologize for being
late because I really did fly in
yesterday and I try to get some sleep so
I would be coherent we shall see this is
a new talk and I am trying to wrap my
mind around some of the effects of the
open Internet in the case of Turkey and
it's just been a fascinating journey now
I'm going to have to take this back a
little bit to before the gezi protests
to explain how a citizen journalism
network started in Turkey and how it
evolved so the first case I have to tell
you to make sense of all of this is a
story that starts about a year before
give the protests when Turkish military
jets under murky conditions bombed a
group of smugglers between the Iraq and
Turkey border who were actually doing
their it you know it's kind of hard to
wrap our mind around this but their
regular smuggling run which they do
routinely and this is in fact a village
that as paid by the government to be
what's called village guards so they
were in good terms with the local
military and the local police and they
waved at them and say they were going on
our smuggling run because that's just
the way it's done except this time
something went wrong something went awry
and the smugglers were bombed by jets it
was a horrible thing 34 people died most
of them in their teens most of them from
one or two families it was horrific what
happened is that the Turkish media knew
of this and sat on the story because
they were waiting for the government to
tell them what to say the older
newsrooms news story they all were
sitting on it they were all skating you
know news and reports from this because
Kurds also have their own media this was
not secret they're all sitting on it the
media censorship in Turkey is
complicated some mix of self-censorship
corporate ownership of media that is
aimed at getting government contracts
and government pressure one journalist
Sardar
who was in the newsroom and just
watching this be censored he just
couldn't take it he was like I can't
take this I just can't sit on this he
purchased the plane ticket with his own
money
he told me he went to the nearby airport
then he got on a taxi and he just went
there and found this enormous scene of
you know this is this is a picture he
put on Instagram of the snaking coffins
of the people who had been blown up and
he broke the story basically to the
Turkish side the Kurds had been hearing
about it they have their own media they
also have social media and this was a
huge shock because I mean here's was a
so clear act of censorship and the
pictures and the interviews I think he
put this on Instagram I mean it's kind
of crazy in other countries you have you
know here's my lunch and in Turkey
here's the you know snaking coffins
after he broke this this was just a
striking wake-up call to lots of people
in a Turkish side especially young
people who had not grown up in the 90s
where the Kurdish Turkish war was a lot
more bloodier and this is sardar on on
their top
your left it's like his pictures from
the area you can see how distraught he
is and three young men later joined by
others in their early 20s we're just
like they were shocked they were really
shocked that they had been subjected to
the censorship and they said let's do
something they told me there might have
been a little bit of alcohol involved
right they were like getting you know
drinking together and saying can't we do
anything can't we do anything and they
decided to form a citizen journalism
network in one evening they said let's
just do this they got a Twitter account
hundred forty journals and somebody sat
and designed the goofy bird for them and
there they were you know just a bunch of
young college students next they started
going around doing what they thought
they could do to do journalism they
started going around and interviewing
people from wherever something was
happening you know this is a gem and
this is onion they're just going to
trials of you know journalists or
they're going to trials off they're
going to protest they just went all
around the country trying to get news at
this time I had already met them and I
was talking with them and I said you
guys aren't really doing citizen
journalism you're doing journalistic
citizenship you're just you know being
journalists and reporting they were like
what can we do you know we're just
trying to get the news out and it's not
being reports that they were doing their
own thing there are a couple more
incidents in which they were crucial
ended up being crucial in breaking news
because journals who were censored
started pirating their news to them
their own outlets wouldn't publish them
so they would go 240 journals and you
know they sort of started building this
network and then the Gizzi protests
happen you might know this story the
gezi protests were in response to the
government's plan for a park in the
middle of one of turkey's sort of
liveliest districts here the government
decided they were gonna put let's see
the replica of an ottoman era barracks
that had once stood there and turn it
into a shopping mall shaped like the
Ottoman barracks I mean it's just it was
the craziest plan and it was this little
bit of Park and it was just gonna
destroy the fabric of that neighborhood
there were huge protests and I've
written about this in many places the
government I'm sorry the mass media once
again sat on the news now when they sat
on the news and the Kurdish areas it
took someone from the Turkish sort of
press going there and breaking the story
when you're sitting on a story that's
happening in Taksim that's kind of like
sitting in a story that's happening on
you know Times Square it's kind of hard
to sit on that one like that what
happened was tons of people heard of
this on social media I went there during
the protest I interviewed hundreds of
people I asked again and again we're to
hear this
Twitter where'd you hear this Twitter
SMS Twitter whatsapp Twitter some
Facebook lots of Twitter so people just
showed up and this became this huge
protest it became so huge that on your
right you can see San an
internationalist covering it life
on your left is Turkish CNN showing a
documentary on Penguins at the same time
so while CNN International is live from
tuckson CNN turkey was showing a
documentary on penguins this became like
the symbol of how crazy media censorship
was and you know somebody just put their
two screens together and tweeted this
out and penguins became the symbol of
the protest so people started
photoshopping penguins and everything
sort of like comes in and it was like
called CNN baiting you know you're
trying to just you know put a picture in
penguins so hoping CNN would cover this
it just became this joke right you saw
penguins were the same I've documented
this myself right this is what's
happening at the same time people are
being guests and the Istiklal Street
which is right next to where the
protests were this is what's on CNN I
mean this is just this kind of
censorship was so blatant
so penguin media versus non penguin
media became the symbol you know to the
the Twitter with the gas buffs because
we're getting guests all the time and
the penguin with the resisting it just
these became the symbols of the protests
because media censorship was a huge part
of what people were protesting to begin
with so this is a you know this was a
graffiti a a from Turkey during gezi if
the revolution will be tweeted that was
the mindset and this also this is a
there was actually humor mag very
confidently called penguin and there's a
wonderful cup a sort of humor
illustrator South Shakera dimitru that
sort of kind of Bansky like and this
became the symbol and that means resist
which is in turkish connotes like occupy
so I went to Gaza Park I went there to
talk to people I want there to interview
people and when I ain't know I just went
around with my helmet because the tear
gas is just uh noise it doesn't kill you
but if it hits your head that's
dangerous and given how I make a living
I had to you know I went there with my
bike helmet and people are asking we're
just scared I was like yes the cab ride
from the
you know from the airport to the park
with no seatbelts and just rushing
through that wasn't fun but other than
that I think it wasn't too bad so what I
found was the citizen journalism s
culture people were she's like I I would
interview people and I would say so what
do you do when you hear something and
you're not sure what's happening and you
would say well I go to the front lines
people would go like somebody showed me
like a wound they got because they're
trying to report from it there was this
enormous sort of before 104 jurors used
to have to go places to report with
Gizzi what we got was this you know as
soon as something happens people started
taking out their phones whatever the
heck they had and reporting and after
gezi protests they're just sort of
organizing citizen journalism became
much easier because the culture changed
and people started reporting like you
know you see the guy pulls ahead is like
that this is such a common thing but so
this is so far reads like our you know
regular story mass media censorship
hundred and forty journals they come in
they report but there's another really
interesting twist to this and this is
the part I'm kind of want to add is that
mass media is often also a tool of
culture war media control in Turkey and
I would say not only in Turkey in a lot
of other examples is not just about
censoring the news it's creating
polarize identities it's creating a
sense of kilter comes around which you
build political basis this is not untrue
in the u.s. right you can't talk about
say saying gun laws because it's become
part of this culture war global warming
has become part of culture world I
identity every and you know hopefully
that sort of that culture war of elites
versus the Heartland kind of cultural
identity gets attached to lower taxes
less public services and that is the
sort of vision through which a lot of
ruling and governance happens in Turkey
this is very very strong the Turkish
polarization is happening through the
media control is not just about
censorship and it can't be at the a in
the age of Internet it's much harder to
maintain this but what's happening is
that
they are the media control is a way of
portraying and demonizing and dividing
the two camps through which the current
government continues to rule now Jessie
Park was a major challenge to this
because it was a very multicultural
space it was I mean besides the fact
that it broke censorship it was this
amazing meeting of a lot of groups that
had been uncomfortable about the
government but were divided internally
the opposition to was divided by these
culture wars so these are some pictures
I took at gizzy and so on your left is
one of turkey's most well known
transgender activists and she became
kind of a hero in gezi park because the
park is near the neighborhood where
turkey's LGBT community lives and she
sat in front of an APC and stopped it
and there were pictures of this so she
became famous on your right is what we
call an aunty from the Kurdish Heartland
and I just saw them find each other or
the Kurdish auntie as we call them went
to her in her thick Kurdish accent and
said why have we talked together before
why didn't we not you know have this and
then the transgender activists and she
was like yes why haven't we and they
hugged and they cried and then I said
can I take a picture they were like sure
so that I mean this is this is not the
kind of cultural groups that would
normally come together in Turkey this is
another picture I took a sort of an
elderly woman what the headscarf era
traditional clothes came by and just
started I was just talking to his buncha
kids he just started crying she said I
can't stand the way they're gassing you
she was just crying cuz these were kids
being gassed and one of the young boy
and I was sitting with and you know you
can't see her face she has tattoos
piercings she's very short so I mean
again cultural wars and they just
consult her another example on your
front is revolutionary Muslims praying
on the back is the sort of a small
socialist party protecting them this was
sort of Gizzi was very anti cultural
camp and that was a big threat so
what happened was government's response
was an all-out culture war on mass media
I'm gonna explain how this ties back to
citizen journalism this was really a
weird case in which the government
claimed that the gezi protesters had
beaten up a woman wearing a hot
headscarf and her baby they claimed that
hundred and fifty she claimed that 150
bare chested leather pant wearing men
had cornered her in the middle of one of
the most crowded places and had beaten
her up and urinated on her so this
incredible claim now this was there
really like the government's really
smart because for years feminists in
Turkey have been arguing for I believe
the women believe that woman believed a
woman and you know she went out on TV
and said this and the government said do
you not believe the woman there are no
pictures there are no sort of other
things besides her testimony so it would
be everyone was kind of taken back
because it had supposedly happened in
one of the most crowded places I was
like not one picture nobody and the idea
was mind blowing
and then this became this huge thing on
this is like Turkish media can you
accept us insanity this kind of
awfulness and you see these cartoons
like the gezi protesters portrayed us
you know people who beat up headscarf
women with their you know with their
babies now the claim there's a lot of
sort of government has a lot of
closed-circuit TVs all around and
finally something leaked so we now know
this is her in 737 this is her three
minutes later she gets in the cab
nothing happened nothing happens so this
was a blatant lie but it took one year
for that frame to leak out and for a
whole year at every rally the Turkish
Prime Minister went and said they beat
up women and babies because they're
wearing the headscarf there were other
similar untested claims like that most
of them were contested because of
citizen journalism I'm saying this
because this is a major part of
the censorship is not censorship per se
right it's a way of creating a cultural
war so seeing all of this the Turkish
140 journalist group started evolving
towards verification counter
polarization and community building and
this is what they've been doing for the
past year because since everybody now
takes out their phone it's become easier
to break censorship in Turkey but
culture wars and media control is the
means of culture Wars has not so here's
some of the things that they're doing
this is a verification example we're in
a little bit after Gizzi there was a
claim a photograph that sort of a
secular organizations building
headquarters in a small town in the
Black Sea region had been surrounded by
mobs who are threatening to burn the
building now in the Turkish context
there are examples of this happening
like mobs burning down buildings of
opposition there's a case in Sivas which
killed about 37 people so this is not a
like crazy idea that this would happen
they were really worried about it and
mass media once again wasn't reporting
but they couldn't really verify that
this was happening because once again
this is a very difficult situation in
which if you cry wolf and if you're
wrong then your credibility is damaged
if you're right and you're not reporting
it you know people may die and this this
is the irony of it this is on the
shoulders of 22 year old college
students because mass media is not
reporting its and they're sitting there
thinking what do we do we're getting
these pictures so they were really like
good what they did was they did a Google
Maps and they identified every shop
around this area and they started
calling him and say hey can you walk to
your balcony and hold your phone to the
you know just out can you just like hold
the phone
something just called and called and
called people till they got somebody to
sort of walk out and do this so it's
really in
seeing how they're doing this
verification they have I think they have
one of the best sort of infrastructure
right now a bunch of college students
have I think one of the best
infrastructures for verifying citizen
journalists and reporters I'm just
giving you one example of what they've
done they have a whole area of
techniques they've developed that they
could talk for hours and hours and hours
on how they verify things and throughout
all of Gizzi in which lots of fall stuff
was circulating they made one minor
mistake and I think they've made one or
two minor mistakes which they
immediately correct since then this is a
year of reporting I don't think mass
media has that good you know they did
that mess me doesn't have this good a
record they've taken their verification
to election monitoring right they
started this thing in with this project
this website where you can take election
reports from your local precinct enter
them and then verify them and this is a
picture of their first meeting like you
know one two three four five people
started this massive election monitoring
it's the same kids the same kids right
and this is just them on Google Hangouts
three of them down there one whiteboard
and they put up the app in a couple of
hours and it date it was just amazing so
what's happening is there's these
official ballot boxes per precinct kind
of and there's an official count and
they've got they got crowdsource
counters so people going like this is
Rihan written so people crowdsource the
writing the hen written one and then
they check it's just a great thing and
it's mapped onto the Turkish sort of
where there's discrepancies pretty
amazing but they're not just doing that
they're doing this counter polarization
reporting they're going out of their way
to report from protests from all sides
so this is a picture that they posted of
Islamists who are praying in the Hagia
Sophia that's the old church that I was
converted into a mosque for a couple
hundred years after
aluminum is and invaded Istanbul which
was before Constantinople and now is a
museum and there's a desire from the
Islamists sort of continually contains
constituency to make it back into a
mosque and they do these weekly prayers
they're 100 and further journals who are
more like the secular kids right they're
not sympathetic necessarily they say
they practice affirmative action they
get up at 4:00 a.m. which is when the
morning prayer is so that they can
report on this in fact they told me
sometimes they just don't go to bed till
4:00 a.m. and they might be a little
hungover they make sure that they report
on this because what they're trying to
do is report everybody else's issues
feelings to each other they are very
much on purpose doing counter polarizing
reporting and they tell me it gets
really weird like they go report on
soccer teams and the soccer fans are
like yay and then they go report from an
LGBT protest and then they're like why
why are you reporting on gays and then
you know every time they report
something one group says why are you
reporting on them and he says over the
years they just kept arguing to everyone
you got to listen to each other so in a
culture in a in a political system in
which culture war is one key way in
which you rule reporting to each other
from each other has become this massive
political statement and sort of let's
sort of close the circle to what
happened to the remember robust key the
kurdish village i told you that had
gotten banned the people the young ones
from that village many of whom everybody
lost someone right the the last names of
the people who died they're all the same
uncle cousin brothers they become
citizen journalists they have themselves
have become citizen journalists and they
now also work with hundred and forty
journals which started because of them
because of upset how upset they were
they report on it so i am one of them is
very hot engine i spoke with him this
time around i went and listened to his
story and it really struck me how does
culture war and censorship
adds to the polarization so he was
telling me how his dad called him in the
middle of the night saying awful news
you know your brother died and
everything and fair hot he was a college
student too
and he got on a bus he got on the first
bus in the morning and he's going to his
village and he told me how I was just
crying in the bus crying crying crying
just devastated and shocked and there's
a television in the bus because in
Turkish buses there are televisions they
just kept looking at the television
where this wasn't reported he said there
was no reporting you know it's already
some people died you know military
bombed my village and he told me how
angry he was he told me how like
devastating he was to sit in that bus
for a couple of hours crying and just
watching the news not be reported he
also told me how when the gezi protests
first started he was angry now that had
never occurred to me that to my shame it
had never occurred to me that you know
someone from a Kurdish background would
be angry because I thought they'd be
happy that you know the western side of
the country was also there was something
going on and he said well you know what
I was so angry because they wouldn't you
know they wouldn't listen to us or
protests about us and they were
protesting about trees so yeah I mean I
can see why you'd be angry I can really
see that he told me he sort of got over
that anger when he started seeing people
getting tear gas and beaten up because
he's occurred right if people are being
beaten up he's just gonna empathize with
it because that's sort of just natural
sympathy and they're they're just you
know very good about this and then he
started saying wait I should empathize
with these people now in gezi Park I
talked to tons of people I've had young
person after young person tell me wait a
minute if we're the terrorists and the
Kurds were terrorists wait a minute you
could see you know I've had kids tell me
that next time there's something in the
Kurdish region they're not gonna turn on
the television they're gonna check
social media they're gonna check hundred
and forty journals and now they can also
check Kurdish citizen journalists
themselves so this character Poehler is
a
through citizen journals and reporting
has been so interesting and so hot now
goes all around sometimes reporting you
know from non Kurdish areas he's just
got this and these are totally
self-funded scrappy things right he had
this phone that was barely working and
it wasn't like he doesn't have the
latest phone he doesn't have latest
equipment he doesn't have anything he
just has himself and of course doing
this he's come under a lot of pressure
he was once detained but when he was
detained his name trended in Turkey on
Twitter because people because he's also
on social media people were so upset
that someone who had lost so much would
still see government pressure so there
was the sort of merger between not it's
not it wasn't just a curse who are
outraged a lot of Turks were outraged
and he was freed he told me that his
followers are his biggest protection and
I and I said are you afraid he said no I
have what's the number now he said I
have you know 20-some thousand followers
and some of them are you know big
important people in Turkey so I feel
more protected and he said if I ever
stop being a citizen journalism they
probably disappear me that was his word
so citizen journaling for him it's very
important and it's really these are
incredible stories they've also become
constant check on mass media there was
an incident in which a young women
jumped from the Bosphorus Bridge to her
death unfortunately and she before
jumping she had taken off her clothes so
she had jumped nude Turkish press of
course covered it's so sensational say
they published the pictures of her
jumping it was just awful her family did
not go object about this to the Turkish
traditional mass media they want 140
journals and they just put this they
said can you publicize this so the
citizen media has become this constant
check on mass media's not just non
reporting and awfulness I mean these are
just some examples I see like people's
tweet 240 journals so things will get
reported and mass media is always
following this
I talked to a lot of reporters they know
that their censorship is gonna be
visible now sort of also to wrap up on
what else had happened Sardar who had
first broken the robots key story to the
Turkish side started something called
Voges TV which was going to be like this
alternative internet-based traditional
media so it wasn't gonna be citizen
media was gonna be traditional media
they got some funding I talked to the
people who did the funding it didn't
work it's really interesting that the
person with him he's a great reporter
he's an amazing reporter with great
journalistic instincts they found the
money but the nuns did their model did
not work so he became a beekeeper right
he gave up after a year of effort now he
became a beekeeper and he's raising
goats and making cheese it's a huge loss
to Turkey I mean that we can't keep our
traditional journalists who want to do
good reporting in spite of funding he
could nine I talked to the people who
funded him and they were like well it
was it was just wasn't sustainable you
can't make money and the government
shuts down your site whereas 140 Germans
because their Twitter based they're a
lot more protected now next steps what
they're doing now I mean this is really
interesting they're trying to do
creating communities through reporting
so they're trying to develop a Twitter
based app Twitter based so that they are
not subject to government censorship
where if you're reporting on something
that's not like national news you have
say animal rights they want to bring
together the people who are reporting on
animals right issues and help them
create their communities and they're
trying to develop these apps of
gamification they have all these I
talked to these kids and it's like
talking to a bunch of little Steve Jobs
in the Civic space they are so creative
and so interesting in their ideas and
they've tried so many things but of
course there's a problem and this is
them this is just us talking the last
time around there's not funding this is
all done and I have just given you maybe
a little slice of all that they've done
in the past couple of years there's
a lot of other stuff they're doing they
are doing this as college students are
going to college who also are doing odd
jobs here and there to completely self
finance 140 journals zero funding
negative funding I mean they have to go
to school and take exams one of them
flunked media new media theory he just
you know missed the exam because he was
giving you know doing all this insane
right this is the kind of 22 year old he
he flunked it because he was that even
talks at Harvard and Princeton by the
way that he was out of town on what they
were doing so the professor was like no
I can't let you do a makeup and flunked
them and he says he barely passed when
he retook a new media theory but there's
just done through this complete scrappy
energy adrenaline and they're really
smart about things you know you talk to
them you know they're there they talk
they develop their own language we keep
trying to find words for what they're
doing they're like we're not really
doing citizen journalism we're going to
be doing community buildings through
reporting I there's no word for this
concept yet they're gonna try me it's a
scanner polarization community building
people finding each other their own
rules of objectivity that doesn't really
map completely I'm they're very very
strong on factual and verification but
they don't mind people having sort of
points of view it's just new it's a new
model of journalism or reporting or
community building whatever you want to
call it and just as this is like and
after I was talking to them there Jim
was like oh I am slipped and you know
one day and he just like crashed on that
yellow sort of pull over there and just
past that it's a total volunteer effort
it's not sustainable like this I mean
there's only so many years you can get
out of young people because one little
hiccup an illness a problem and you will
get
and to think so and this is why I like
some of the examples that we have is
that we have Center for civic media all
these things that are being tried I love
it the personal democracy forum is
started trying to start like a civic
startup in New York which I think is a
great idea we really I think need to
expand to global and need to expand
globally to risky on non ventures our
funding model of funding a little more
guaranteed stuff is the opposite of what
Silicon Valley does and I'm guessing
like Silicon Valley's got a lot of
problems but they're so good at just
this crazy funding which we laugh at
we're like why is everybody funding the
crazy stuff well because if you don't
fund the crazy stuff you don't get the
interesting stuff either right Silicon
Valley has this ecology of crazy angel
investors and a lot of money and a lot
of young people who want to do something
and they do get something done in the
end and I've been thinking you know
we've been talking about this with Ethan
Zuckerman I've been talking about this
with Mika she free other people we
really need to bring the sort of culture
of funding with less strings attached
just to this stuff to civic startups to
civic media and to third-world because
that's where a lot of the innovation is
occurring right you know in pesos starts
in Kenya for a reason there is a need
and there's a lot of people are smart
and great and and whenever it goes to
someplace like that I'm just blown away
but how much stuff gets done how do we
do this I I don't really know because
it's a challenging funding environment
you can't just fund success and get
success because the successful people
already successful cannot fund
guaranteed projects if this is gonna
work because I assure you 140 journals
wasn't the only one that started right
so you have to create this and there has
to be some failure in experimentation
built into how we fund these things I
mean I think like the night news
challenge did 104 jurors they applied
and got rejected by the way they're
trying to develop an application to
create this community building and
gamification because none of them are
programmers and they can't afford to
hire a programmer hey they've been stuck
in we can't afford to hire a programmer
in the past year so they they didn't get
funded they know they're trying because
it's harder you know it's harder to
apply from Turkey it's harder to apply
the sort of the grant-making language
that you need the success you already
need and I don't really have an answer
to this but there are so many exactly
and this is just one project in Turkey
there right now tons of projects I think
this is one of the best I think they're
great and really smart but they're not
even they're not even the only one
and I'm guessing other countries have
all of this so I just wanted to end on
this how do we create a civic startup
culture that flourishes all of these you
know besides the few places we have here
you know the media of the Civic Media
Center or other places so thank you for
your thank you so much setup and please
don't go anywhere you can give me the
clicker if you want but we're not
letting you off stage just yet despite
skillfully planning this so that you
would avoid Q&A we've we've squeezed in
ten minutes so I wanted to make sure we
could get at least a couple of questions
to you while we have you here so those
of you please great get hands up and I
will start running around with the mic
and we won't have time for everybody but
we'll see what we can do here and I know
that sign ups around for the rest of the
morning people I talked to like I think
4 p.m. I have a fire fantastic just
catch me here we go
and there I'm Dan a priest what's been
the government's reaction how you doing
and a lot of journalists have been
imprisoned lately and yet Turkey are
they related
yes 40 journals yes so here's the
interesting thing they have not yet
faced direct government threats it's an
interesting case because part of what
they're doing is reporting very very
carefully verified things from citizen
journalists so and they've been
reporting from all sides so that's a
little harder for the government to
target them but if they get bigger and
more successful that's a real
issue for them but because they're also
on Twitter see the Turkish government
the the censorship in Turkey on places
like also Russia right it's not always
it's not the censorship is very much
also self-censorship by the main media
corporations the number of jail
journalists there's a lot of sort of
contested numbers there and it certainly
happens right the Turkish government
does jail some journalists but to be
honest the bigger problem is that there
is no media corporate media in which
journalists are free that is a much
bigger problem and that happens by the
government pressuring the media
corporations and also industrial sort of
big industrial conglomerates go by media
and then they use the media as a means
to curry favor with the government so
that really is like rather than being
jailed being pressured it's kind of like
the Putin's way of getting NGOs because
the radiator needs to be three inches
from the wall and it's two and a half
inches right and then you're shut down
that's what's been happening since
they're just scrap your little startup
on Twitter they're harder to pressure
that way and they're not breaking any
laws very carefully they're not breaking
any laws in Turkey there's not really
major laws against reporting a lot of
things a lot of it is just sort of the
government they did the guy we know that
things have been leaked at the
government the Prime Minister personally
telephones heads of mass media
organizations in Turkey when he doesn't
like the ticker he calls and says I
don't like your ticker and the guy on
the other end says yes sir and he
admitted he made this call sorry this is
like this audio leaked and it was like
of course I call I didn't like the
ticker I you know I have a right to call
when I don't like the ticker so that's
how the censorship is occurring and they
wouldn't listen if you called him and
said take off your thing so they're kind
of protected by not being very
institutional not being in this for the
money now well if they really like if
they made a mistake a
you know they could get sued on their
personal defamation and all of other
things and so far that's what's going on
my name is Santa Paula I'm from Romania
Eastern Europe we closely watched what
is happening in Turkey and in Ukraine
and the way the government's is
censoring the information and I would
like you to elaborate a little bit about
how the government is cutting off the
access to Twitter YouTube to internet
specific websites with disseminating
information is criticizing the
government because this is I think very
interesting and another additional
question if you can explain a little bit
how they do it they are calling directly
the companies the phone company so this
is a very interesting it's a great
question because see as far as I can
tell in the world there are three and a
half models of Internet censorship one
is China and I think Rebecca's in the
room MacKinnon yeah you can read all
about it from her it's an amazing
infrastructure right you have your tech
scene you have your direct access to the
government has direct access to WIPO and
you have to have been China to do that
you needed to have started 20 years ago
with that kind of foresight so Turkey is
not doing it like China won the health
model is North Korea right just have no
internet except know who the heck wants
to be North Korea nobody on the planet
besides North Korea wants to be North
Korea so Turkey doesn't want to be North
Korea Turkey has one of the most amazing
youthful eager Minh infrastructures in
the world it's better than the u.s.
hands down this government cannot
operate without the internet everything
you do with the government you know if
you have a primary care doctor through
the government's health insurance you
use the internet to make your
appointment that is partly why the
government's popular they have used the
Internet to create this amazing
infrastructure that makes life much more
convenient so there's no way they can
unplug the Internet they would you know
they just that's not gonna work so what
do they do they go after these platforms
except that doesn't terribly work
because when they went after Twitter
what happened was people just got around
the block you can use a VPN since you
can't unplug the Internet it's not very
easy but it did slow down access to
Twitter right so if you had to go
through VPN it's slow down access which
was a major problem for people but in
time that would have gotten solved
people would start getting you know paid
VPNs and things so people who would
likely have solved that problem so you
can't really sensor that so what do they
do they make it part of the cooter
comfort they make it part of culture
wars the Prime Minister goes on TV all
the time and says Twitter is where there
is porn and anti Family Values and lies
and it will defame you it will break up
your family what they're doing in Turkey
and I see this like I wrote this up as
soon as I wrote this up like people from
around the world started saying my
government to Indonesia you know my
Malaysia every day lots of places are
going this Third Way which is demonizing
social media so your own base stays off
it so that you can go continue your
culture war because unless you're china
it's really not possible to do this
massive filter it's just not gonna work
attacking you know every YouTube they
block YouTube and the government's base
why you know today there's a lot of
popular cartoons in Turkey there they
use YouTube to make doing you know let
their kids watch that stuff they were
are not happy about it you know the
government's own base was like I wonder
what you know and watch Caillou and
Pippin what the heck right and also
Turks are really good at circumvention
because the government's been blocking
porn sites for years and there's no
better training in circumvention
apparently especially in the Middle East
it's like everybody knew how to
circumvent so sir convention is well
understood very widespread you know
whether it's to get to porn sites or to
watch Caillou cartoons like you know
grandmas know how to change their DNS
settings so that the kids can watch kyai
I'm not kidding so it's the blocking
doesn't totally work but you can slow
down
throttle and you can make it part of the
culture war you see this in country
after country where people go and like
leaders go and say Internet is awful
ugly evil Azerbaijan does this what
happens is that their own base stays off
Twitter it's not that Twitter stays
unaccessible so it's really important
for Silicon Valley to sort of understand
this and kind of figure out what they do
in response they're gonna be demonized
they have to be careful they have to
have their help pages in turkish they
have to like localize without giving in
to the sort of just the censorship per
se it's a complicated long story and i
think this is what we're going to see in
a lot of places demonization throttling
culture war in which internet is part of
it the prime minister famously during
gives said Twitter's a menace to society
and that's what he meant
so the wonderful thing about bringing
Tok top academics to the stage is that
you get answers to questions you never
expected to have answers to
I now know who actually watches Caillou
I I have to say I'm a parent of a four
and a half year old I never thought
there was an audience it's in Turkey
this is important for me to know Zana
incredibly helpful thank you so glad
you're gonna be around for the rest of
the day I hope people will seek stand-up
out over lunch over breaks we don't
actually have breaks but if we did you
would find her then and in the meantime
a round of applause to thank her thank
you thank you so much for inviting me
[Applause]